[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday May 19th a
pleasant but rainy day here in
Indianapolis and today's video comes to
you in three parts part 1 why I smell
funny if YouTube had smell-o-vision by
the way Google you like a trillion
dollar company with some of the
brightest people in the world working
for you make me some smell-o-vision then
you might be asking John am I crazy or
have you been swimming in a big vat of
horse manure well first I think
everybody knows you can't swim in horse
manure the consistency just doesn't
allow for it but yes I do smell like
horse manure it's because I went to this
place in Indianapolis where they give
away free horse poop you may remember
that last year when the Yeti and I moved
to Indianapolis and we got to our house
and we noticed that we had like a
gigantic front lawn that was a complete
waste of space and energy and water we
sort of freaked out and what we really
wanted to do was rip up our lawn
entirely and replace it with native
plants and vegetables but here's the
thing Hank the only thing I fear more
than our planet becoming uninhabitable
to humans is my neighbors thinking that
I'm a crazy liberal so what we're doing
instead is we're slowly ripping out our
lawn there's our brand-new vegetable bed
in a place that used to have grass
that's right Hank and probably enough
inch by inch row by row I am becoming a
gardener part two I forgot what part two
was supposed to be oh right you're early
belated birthday present your proper
belated birthday present will be coming
later in the week but I didn't want to
wait to show you what nerdfighter in
Bangladesh Shawn got you so here's what
Shawn did with the Xbox money you sent
him he went to an extremely rural part
of Bangladesh a part of Bangladesh that
almost no non-governmental organizations
are working in I mean there are no like
cars or anything he had to cross this
bridge to get there this family's been
struggling to keep their kids in school
your money is gonna help them do that
also everyone in the family except for
the father has suffered from malaria at
least once
Shawn brought them this mosquito net
that's going to allow them to live
without malaria for years to come also
and this really sucks their roof leaks
onto their bed your money's gonna fix
that so isn't that sort of miraculous
Hank that you're looking at the actual
people that your actual money is
actually helping all of us who donated
to help Shawn reduce world suck in
Bangladesh will be experiencing that
miracle soon as he begins to distribute
more of the funds unfortunately it takes
him a while to get videos up because you
know he's in Bangladesh but we'll keep
track of what he's up to link to his
YouTube channel in the sidebar or
possibly in the sidebar that's a hard
finger moustache to do part three on
Nixon airy nerdfighters as some of you
know Hank and I have been working on a
semi secret project which is kind of
like a wiki only instead of being about
facts it's about lies on Nixon airy is
what the Wikipedia like reference source
and Paper Towns is called
and since Hank acquired on Nixon airy
calm for me we felt like we should do
something interesting with it and so
what Hank and I did is we made a wiki
and we took some terminology from Paper
Towns and some of the world from Paper
Towns and we basically wrote a story
that was entirely different from Paper
Towns and also a story that doesn't
really have a beginning or a middle or
an end and that nerdfighters is where
you come in this probably isn't going to
work but our idea is that in the same
way that Wikipedia is a user created
encyclopedia omniscient Ericom can
become a kind of user created novel
leaders of um Nick shanira will pick how
they read it in the same way that we
choose how we read Wikipedia and instead
of being written by one person it will
be written by everybody
so far most of the entries have been
written either by me or by Hank or by a
talented young writer named Emily
Johnson but now I am officially opening
up I'm Nick shanira to the world you can
rewrite the story as you see fit if
you're like me and you're always looking
for new and interesting ways to read and
be read by other writers this seems to
me like a pretty jokes opportunity link
in the sidebar or I'm gonna do it better
this time link in the sidebar I have got
to work on my sense of direction
nerdfighters thank you for all your
questions please keep them coming it's
going to be too awesome question
Tuesday's this week and Hank you'll see
me tomorrow